In this video, we'll
create a heat map
on a map of the United States.
We'll be using the data
set murders.csv, which
is data provided
by the FBI giving
the total number of murders
in the United States by state.
Let's start by reading
in our data set.
We'll call it murders, and
we'll use the read.csv function
to read in the data
file murders.csv.
Let's take a look at the
structure of this data
using the str function.
We have 51 observations
for the 50 states
plus Washington, DC, and
six different variables:
the name of the state, the
population, the population
density, the number
of murders, the number
of murders that used guns,
and the rate of gun ownership.
A map of the United
States is included
in R. Let's load the map
and call it statesMap.
We can do so using
the map_data function,
where the only argument
is "state" in quotes.
Let's see what this looks like
by typing in str(statesMap).
This is just a data
frame summarizing
how to draw the United States.
To plot the map, we'll use the
polygons geometry of ggplot.
So type ggplot, and then in
parentheses, our data frame
is statesMap, and then
our aesthetic is x = long,
the longitude variable
in statesMap, y = lat,
the latitude variable,
and then group = group.
This is the variable
defining how
to draw the United States
into groups by state.
Then close both
parentheses here,
and we'll add geom_polygon
where our arguments here will be
fill="white"-- we'll just
fill all states in white--
and color="black" to
outline the states in black.
Now in your R
graphics window, you
should see a map of
the United States.
Before we can plot
our data on this map,
we need to make sure
that the state names are
the same in the
murders data frame
and in the statesMap data frame.
In the murders data
frame, our state names
are in the State
variable, and they
start with a capital letter.
But in the statesMap data
frame, our state names
are in the region variable,
and they're all lowercase.
So let's create a new variable
called region in our murders
data frame to match the state
name variable in the statesMap
data frame.
So we'll add to our murders
data frame the variable region,
which will be equal to
the lowercase version--
using the tolower function that
we used in the text analytics
lectures-- and the argument
will be murders$State.
This will just convert
the State variable
to all lowercase
letters and store it
as a new variable called region.
Now we can join the statesMap
data frame with the murders
data frame by using the
merge function, which
matches rows of a data frame
based on a shared identifier.
We just defined the
variable region,
which exists in
both data frames.
So we'll call our new
data frame murderMap,
and we'll use the
merge function,
where the first argument is our
first data frame, statesMap,
the second argument is our
second data frame, murders,
and the third argument
is by="region".
This is the identifier
to use to merge the rows.
Let's take a look
at the data frame
we just created using
the str function.
We have the same
number of observations
here that we had in the
statesMap data frame,
but now we have both the
variables from the statesMap
data frame and the variables
from the murders data
frame, which were matched up
based on the region variable.
So now, let's plot
the number of murders
on our map of the United States.
We'll again use the ggplot
function, but this time,
our data frame is murderMap,
and in our aesthetic we want
to again say x=long,
y=lat, and group=group,
but we'll add one more
argument this time,
which is fill=Murders so that
the states will be colored
according to the
Murders variable.
Then we need to add the
polygon geometry where the only
argument here will
be color="black"
to outline the states
in black, like before.
And lastly, we'll add
scale_fill_gradient where
the arguments here, we'll put
low="black" and high="red"
to make our color scheme
range from black to red,
and then guide="legend" to
make sure we get a legend
on our plot.
If you hit Enter and look
at your graphics window now,
you should see that
each of the states
is colored by the number
of murders in that state.
States with a larger number
of murders are more red.
So it looks like
California and Texas
have the largest
number of murders.
But is that just because they're
the most populous states?
Let's create a map of the
population of each state
to check.
So back in the R Console,
hit the Up arrow, and then,
instead of fill=Murders, we want
to put fill=Population to color
each state according to
the Population variable.
If you look at the
graphics window,
we have a population
map here which
looks exactly the same
as our murders map.
So we need to plot the
murder rate instead
of the number of murders
to make sure we're not just
plotting a population map.
So in our R Console,
let's create
a new variable for
the murder rate.
So in our murderMap data frame,
we'll create the MurderRate
variable, which is equal
to murderMap$Murders--
the number of murders-- divided
by murderMap$Population times
100,000.
So we've created a
new variable that's
the number of murders
per 100,000 population.
Now let's redo our plot with
the fill equal to MurderRate.
So hit the Up arrow twice to get
back to the plotting command,
and instead of fill=Population,
this time we'll put
fill=MurderRate.
If you look at your
graphics window now,
you should see that the plot
is surprisingly maroon-looking.
There aren't really
any red states.
Why?
It turns out that
Washington, DC is
an outlier with a
very high murder rate,
but it's such a small
region on the map
that we can't even see it.
So let's redo our plot,
removing any observations
with murder rates
above 10, which
we know will only
exclude Washington, DC.
Keep in mind that when
interpreting and explaining
the resulting plot,
you should always
note what you did to
create it: removed
Washington, DC from the data.
So in your R Console, hit the
Up arrow again, and this time,
after guide="legend", we'll type
limits=c(0,10) and hit Enter.
Now if you look back at
your graphics window,
you can see a range
of colors on the map.
In this video, we saw how
we can make a heat map
on a map of the
United States, which
is very useful for organizations
like the World Health
Organization or government
entities who want to show data
to the public organized
by state or country.
In the next video,
we'll conclude
by discussing the analytics
edge of predictive policing.